hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einem video wo ich mir
nachher wieder sagen wer hey wieso hab
ich so was gemacht wir spielen nämlich
heute das spiel
ich komme ganz gut was es heißt aber
dass alexander humboldt gymnasium es ist
eine reinigung und kanalsanierung yahoo
hvh steht für virtual holz ja wir
spielen heute ein spiel mit pferden ich
habe mich gerade auf dieser seite
angemeldet unter dem namen reiter luca
denn das ist mein name und ich konnte
mir ein pferd aussuchen und zwar ist das
hier das sieht vielleicht auf den ersten
blick aus wie ein zebra ist es auch für
lache ich dieses ziel habe ich dann
chantal genannt weil ich dachte der name
passt und was wir jetzt machen können
weiß ich nicht ganz genau wie wurde halt
nur letztens in die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich mal wieder ein
faires spiel
wieso eigentlich mal wieder ich hab noch
nie fertig spiel gespielt ich sollte mal
was mit pferden machen also total süß
dieser kleine tüte und sagt uns sieht
joas klick und mit viel action video
it's ok das heißt wir klicken hier drauf
you do not have to video horse video
ende wir können mit unserem coins glaub
ich hier
geld anlegen
und geld abheben
ich will aber was kaufen
hier können wir uns mit paypal geld
kaufen
so finanziert sie also die seite wir
haben bisher 0 experience das ist auch
schön zu lesen und kann ich nicht hier
irgendwie mal auf was habe ich denn
qui
hier kann ich fragen stellen power-duo
get money
juli vor adidas depression hoch ihr
könnt ihr auch auf magic awards gehen da
kommt you don't have any medical alterns
okay wenn ich auf magic items decke
kommt
das gleiche wieder ich klicke auf die
nachrichten und auch dass die maschinen
unter kann hier berichte schreiben sehe
ich gerade schreibe jetzt meine
nachricht an reiter luca mit dem betreff
gib mir geld und dem text ein need money
dann senden wir das ganze event center
letter to reiterlook hab ich den jetzt
bekommen um gott ich habe eine nachricht
und zwar von reiter luca und da drin
steht
wo bin ich wir geben einfach in die tür
hier oben rein youtube
da mich drauf headliner kommt mir dass
meine nachricht angekommen
mit level in more player ab märz
tatsächlich jemand geantwortet innerhalb
von fünf minuten außer org apps ist noch
niedrig aus talk about cats das heißt
ich muss meinen spieler ab level wie ich
das mache
mein pferd stirbt gerade ich geh mal
hier oben in die tür rein da kommt judah
valley medical alters und wenn ich jetzt
rein theoretisch mal hier in die tür
eingehe kommt wir sind in einem raum
es ist wahrscheinlich so was wo ich
meine frau wenigen wir einpacken kann
von denen habe ich aber einfach noch
keine hier ist ein bild von
was ist denn das jetzt hier ich kann
jetzt mal auf wackligen rennen sehe ich
wie ich irgendwie
auch nicht okay wir waren jetzt in
dieser terin da ging ja nichts hier was
bilden wir können hier unten kann ich
noch hin und da haben wir
die karte zwei grad irgendwie
verschwunden habe ich sicher dass ich
unglaublich viele items habe und
überhaupt nicht weiß was sich damit
anstellen soll
ich will eigentlich einfach nur mal eben
mein pferd füttern ich kann ja nicht mal
das hier nehmen und darüber ziehen
das macht ja auch gar keinen sinn
irgendwie hatte ich habe ihn jetzt mal
gesagt dass ich ein fünf jahre altes
mädchen bin und gerade kurz davor bin zu
weinen weil ich nicht hallo cent/kwh es
schon jetzt hier mal wenn man eine
auszeichnung vergeben könnte für das
schlimmste spielewelt dann wäre
definitiv dieses spiel denn ich kann
nicht mal eine frage an die helpline
senden wir gehen jetzt einfach mal in
die bank und klicken auf trends fördern
kann ich jetzt an mich selbst
habe ich jetzt an mich selbst geld für
wasser mal wenigstens meine sache die
ich mal jetzt habe ich aus dem fenster
gezogen jetzt das mache ich es derzeit
gegen die ganze zeit auf mein pferd
deswegen weiß ich gar nicht was ich hier
irgendwie man geht in vrees doch jetzt
einfach mal irgendwas die schönste
nachricht ich im ganzen spiel bisher
bekommen habe ein need money
von reiter luca ich hab den jetzt mal
geschrieben dass ich nicht weiß wie ich
jetzt hier ganz genau starten soll
weil ich überhaupt keinen plan ab wie
ich überhaupt meinen vertreter sollte so
dass es nicht stirbt das einzige was
dieser typ ion noch macht es
komisch gucken okay wir gehen jetzt noch
mal alles der reihe nach durch wir sind
hier in diesem zimmer wir können hier
nicht reingehen weil dann kommen diese
komischen magical items wenn ich dann
aber rein theoretisch auf dieses bild
clique dann komme ich nur wieder zu
dieser komischen sache wo ich hier nicht
sehe was ich hier
okay ich bin 31 ich muss in die level
hoch kommen aber ich weiß ja nicht wie
ich habe auch einfach gar keine skills
überall 0
an dieser tür ist nur noch einen ganzen
trophäen von ich noch gar keine besitze
und wenn ich dann rein theoretischen
durchgehe bin ich bei einer karte die
nicht lebt
wer entwickelt so was ich dachte echt
wir können jetzt super cool mit unserem
pferd spielen und so aber unser pferd
ist einfach ein zebra irgendwie chantal
ich mag dich aber ich glaube leider dass
du sterben wirst ich muss das video
leider hier beenden weil ich nach 130
minuten bin fragt mich nicht wie ich das
der zehn gekriegt habe das frage ich
mich auch gerade wenn es euch gefallen
getan habe ich mich meine wertung freuen
und wenn ihr
ich glaube ich brauche nicht fragen aber
ich glaube keiner spielt dieses spiel
ich habe von jedoch noch nicht wieder
eine neue antwort bekommen aber naja
wenn irgendwelche ideen was man noch
machen kann
ihr wolltet reiterspiele ich habe einst
gespielt das war scheiße